look at how fast spider-ham is okay wait
yeah well we'll put this what's up
everybody I'm Peter and as you may
remember I am working on my very own
spider-man short film which is
thankfully almost done let me show you
something this is kind of the place
where I sleep at night master bed and
little trick that I learned which makes
it a lot better as you can take these
little flaps and now you got more leg
space I've got a pillow right here the
only thing that kind of sucked is that
there's not enough room to spread out
and so you'll always wake up with one
arm asleep here's the VFX spreadsheet
all of the green is shots I've completed
black is shots I've cut out look at all
this completion almost done baby
final stretch I have about 20 visual
effects shots left to do excluding just
some green screen stuff which I can
pretty much automate so I have three
days to do 23 shots which if you ask me
is pretty manageable because these
aren't full CGI shots I have finished
all of those thank goodness and now
these are the kind of lower caliber VFX
shots that I have left I'll send them
off to Ren see if he can take care of
them so now I just have 22 low caliber
VFX shots left to do and then I will
send it off for music and sound and it
will be all done going into this project
I was like sure I'll have 150 VFX shots
many of which include character
animations something I've never done
before even as I was thinking that in
the back of my mind somewhere I was like
there's no subscribe way I'm gonna do
this this is an insane amount of work
and it's really dumb for me to set
myself up to fail like this yeah
laughably I thought I would have
done by summer 2018 before I even got to
corridor I thought all edited on my
surface broke
[Music]
now that I have these very nice
computers to work with I have let me
calculate the hours I've spent working
on this sixty days at ten to twelve
hours each
almost 700 hours I spent on
post-production and it's barely enough
to finish I'm literally getting by on
the skin of my teeth here I have not
learned a good lesson about managing
expectations throughout this project
because I had unrealistic expectations
and it all worked out
so I guess I'll just keep doing that
keep paying the price for it
I love spider-man I'll always love
spider-man we're here today in the
corridor Digital Studios
studio maybe it's maybe it's the plural
maybe singular I don't know point is
we're here to talk about foam for
tonight
Foam blasters for tonight together we
did nerf team fortress we did nerf John
wick foam fort night seemed like a
natural evolution in that process so
here we are
Clint has created a very competent
script Jarrett and Christian myself are
here to figure out exactly how to go
about this because we have two weeks
from tomorrow to figure everything out
for this video so that location there is
a town outside of Yosemite called
Yosemite Valley
yeah that's generally the area I think
this is perfect because it's green you
got it Christmas trees you got your
Christmas you had even have rivers maybe
a lake it looks like so I think this
hits a lot of the aesthetic that you get
before tonight you know it's very green
it's very vivid
your balloons you got your greens got
your crispy trees it's pretty much the
easiest cleanest way to go
production-wise so it's five and a half
hours by car which is totally drivable
in an afternoon so so let's talk about
this yeah how many days of production do
you think we need to cover the main part
up to the birthday party I think I can
do too well yeah how many days I played
rugby that's always more always more
always always more days are best I mean
if we got three days dude we can make
this look like real nice take our time
on this you know we can we can have two
three takes we can do three takes we got
action right yeah we got run under we
got a gun we got some walls we gotta
throw up we have some VFX plays we gotta
get we got some acting moments to hit
yeah there's a few more layers to this
script than usual we need a day before
we start photography to just play a plan
and scout and get everything in order so
that's a five-day total plus a day
travel back so you're talking about a
six day time frame currently Jarret is
working on all of the fortnight props
it's Jared basically we've got to have
those done by the end of the week and
we're making some sweet sweet foam
fortnight weapons 49 is very cartoony
when a designer for a video game is
drawing these things the sky's the limit
right so they just do all these
shenanigans and throw weird fun designs
on there and it doesn't matter because
it's not real and it can just be there
you know we could build this from foam
from scratch we could 3d print things we
could do a lot but we don't have the
time of the budget today to manage the
expectations of our creator you should
go big right when you're when you're
first coming down with your idea be as
big as possible and then start cutting
back to reality say well you can't do
that I can't quite do that what we can
do this but we can sort of make things
into real life so this week we grabbed
this is a g36 is the sub machine gun so
we just took one that we had I took some
of the parts off of it gave it the paint
job and then since
I have three barrels I've made these
which I'm going to put on here and then
I've done a third to glue onto there to
match so it's gonna be like this this is
the a K that's in the game so then I
made this boy so you can see it's
similar still cartoony but real bringing
cartoons into reality poses some
challenges because you're like well what
are these parts do who knows it doesn't
matter just needs to look like something
so does it look cool in the video it's
all I care about I think I can get the
rest is done today it's a matter of
managing time and then next week there's
a lot of build up set pieces could go
faster than expected so I might have
some more time but the goal is to have
this done tomorrow night and if that
means I stay late
means I stay like we get it done oh yeah
man mmm this shot right here is
definitely one of the beefiest shots in
the entire short there are so many
buildings random objects in the city
people walking around cars with all the
reflections the street everything is in
this shot and this computer handles it
and beautifully so much so that I can
see the final rendered version as I work
here's what it looks like without
rendering and this is pretty much what
it'll look like once it's finished
and the fact that I can see that while I
work is insanely helpful for having
speedy workflow and being efficient
before I moved my post-production work
to corridor I was working off of a
laptop for something like this was just
not cutting it there was no way I was
going to be able to do big fancy shots
with just a laptop at puget has been so
huge and helping me make this project
look at how fast this computer is
rendering spider-man damn maybe they're
not normal no yeah look how fast it can
render how thick spider-man is it's dude
oh my God look at that do you think a
surface pro could render that uh-huh
guys really have five more days to buy
the shirts looted edition that means
once we stop selling it it's gone
forever we're going to make as many as
are ordered so 5 days left to get your
order in it now don't do a get it